thrusting outward into space
we gain new perspective on ourselves
perhaps no new development in space is
more significant than this
hurts
short for earth resources
technology satellite
[Music]
ertz later named landsat 1 was one of
the first satellites to take regular
snapshots of the earth
on board were two sensors a camera and a
multi-spectral scanner
while the camera showed the world as we
see it in the visible spectrum of light
the multi-spectral scanner also captured
data in the near infrared spectrum
researchers at nasa anticipated that
data from this sensor could help monitor
the health of vegetation
here's a black and white picture of the
monterey bay area in california produced
by the infrared channel on the earth's
multispectral scanner
now if we project this image through a
green filter the lighter gray tones
which are vegetation such as the form
areas in the great valley will show up
more green
today data of reflected light beyond the
visible spectrum have been used for a
variety of applications from measuring
the productivity of plants to assessing
the microbial inhabitants in soil
many satellites are equipped with more
advanced sensors and cameras such as
landsat 8 and 9 and sentinel-2a and 2b
other ways to survey the earth such as
lidar scanners which use lasers to
measure distances from earth generate 3d
imagery
in recent decades researchers have used
remote sensing data to understand the
biodiversity of an ecosystem
researchers studying the lagrange
mountains near zurich switzerland have
harnessed a bevy of these techniques to
characterize the forest's health
by calculating leaf area from satellite
imagery and gauging tree heights using
lidar researchers estimated the
productivity of the forest
they also flew over the area using an
airplane equipped with hyperspectral
sensors which picked up hundreds of
bands of light
by grouping similar signatures of light
together researchers calculated the
abundance of different species of trees
these data also helped them capture
finer scale details trees have unique
concentrations of pigment water content
and chlorophyll that cause them to
reflect light differently the unique
combination of these physiological
traits allowed researchers to map the
functional diversity of the forest floor
diverse ecosystems are better equipped
to handle changes such as drought or
disease outbreaks
in combination with these techniques
from high in the sky researchers
collected samples on the ground to
validate their findings combining these
approaches allows for a more
comprehensive way to understand the
health of an ecosystem and in turn where
to prioritize conservation efforts
one conservation project for endangered
siberian white cranes used remote
sensing to evaluate suitable habitats
after examining a small three kilometer
square area where the birds bred the
researchers found that the cranes
avoided breeding in areas where shrubs
were invading the wetlands
the researchers used satellite imagery
to scan a 16 000 square kilometer area
mostly inaccessible by foot to find more
promising areas where the cranes could
thrive
scientists hope to extend these
techniques to even more species
one project map of life lays out the
distribution of over 44 000 species of
flora and fauna using a combination of
remote sensing techniques
since there are a limited number of
conservationists and ecologists to
physically survey species remote sensing
allows biodiversity researchers to more
quickly get an idea of potential at-risk
populations
as well as the areas where organisms are
thriving and biodiversity is high
many researchers are excited about the
possibility of what they can monitor as
the resolution and frequency of remote
sensing data improves